vir would have ruled out Peter Crouch's
goal versus Trinidad and Tobago in 2006.
disagree so badly I wanted it but we're
doing a serious show here you can't go
pulling dreadlocks yeah welcome
[Music]
hi Joe hello geese I sound all good
great to see you good to see ya crispy
peachy
I've got a question for you Sammy Lee's
nicknames are they the best in football
oh without a doubt unbelievable
strongly agree no could you explain
crispy to me where did these come from
it was crispy peachy so so do you know
why it was no idea crispy just accepted
it
peachy I don't I'll get I think it's
sensitive P yeah and then it just
develops into peachy crispy duck I think
he started off crispy duck and then he
dropped the duck
no idea what Duke the Duke was John
Terry yeah rizz rizz Rio that's pretty
self-explanatory there's no one else
they never caught on did they
[Laughter]
oh that's my question
Lionel Messi will be the best player at
the 2022 World Cup
three two one
well he's the best player
I think the question
prove it again really prove it one of
the things you say you say prove it
again because as he proven it in a World
Cup yeah and that's oh he's always
getting compared a tournament at the
World Cup in uh uh not the last one the
one before weren't it yeah sure he did
yeah he did but yeah Maradona dragged
Argentina to World Cups and I think
there's always a comparison between
officers for obvious reasons but when
you're Maradona and you win uh obviously
the series yeah with uh Napoli you
dragged that team yeah we were you know
down the bottom of the league too
winning the title drag a country they
still had some incredible flights
he's dragged us to a World Cup no listen
there you go east inside but what I'm
saying is he's won the World Cup yeah
lifted it yeah like does he think he's
seen as a fighter if he doesn't no no no
no like it just leaves the argument open
like you know if you're speaking to
someone else I think if if Argentina win
a World Cup messy Stars I think it's
pretty much not even to say don't win it
even if they don't win it I still think
he's the greatest player that's ever
played the game could he can he be the
best player in the tournament is the
question
I do have you seen I've watched
Argentina playing I went to watch the uh
the game against Italy when they played
at Wembley to finally the finalists in
my way mate he was different gear I was
like blown away just watching him as a
fan and it was just I was like Wow and
then he's hit the right that was at the
end of last season he hit the ground
running this year he's on his own form
Ed they haven't lost in 35 games or
something Argentina
but it's I I think he'll I think
regardless of whether Argentina win it
or not I think he'll still perform and
he'll be the best player yeah there's
obviously Benzema uh Neymar bat paid his
players
that can easily be playing at all yeah
but a safe bet is messy yeah I think
regardless if they win it or not
he could easily be Golden Boot yeah so
you have to strongly agree with it yeah
Joe Cole scored England's best World Cup
goal ever in 2006. three two one
so I thought I thought about this one
like a little bit
like David Platts brings to mind against
Belgium yeah just because of the moment
yeah 1990 for me was the best World Cup
but I'm taking I'm taking the the point
of the game out of it yeah I'm looking
at the goal yeah gaza's goal was in
Euros like yeah which was probably the
the next best one Michael Owen Michael
Owens World Cup goal against
um yeah I forgot about that one
[Laughter]
if you take out the um
that all the scenarios like Michael
being 18 yeah uh well I think Michaels
was better
[Laughter]
what's it like to score a World Cup yeah
like it was amazing and it wasn't a gold
I would usually never shoot from that
distance
um like it was just before half time
and the ball just just set up and I'm
just thinking to myself you know like
because we used to practice this we I
remember I remember practicing at chubby
Leaf paintbrush the paintbrush exactly
the old school terminology right Lads
we're going to do the paintbrush now and
the coach would get it get it and they'd
throw it to your chest then you'd take a
chest and you just and the goalkeepers
hated it because they could never
because you put a spin on it they can't
judge it they're against the dip so I
thought just before half time well it
felt just before I travel back I'm gonna
have a pop here and just if it goes in
the stands it goes in the stands but use
for a good connection good and as soon
as I hit it for all that's got a chance
last question just dipped and dipped in
and it went in and I think he was the
first one to me but he was at the far
post so that's probably the quickest
you've run in your career
to get to me to that corner if you I
actually went out for because I was
actually my assist yeah yeah yeah it
goes down as an assist because I was the
last England player to touch the ball
um I headed it into nowhere they cleared
it and then you did that so I'm claiming
it
whenever I'm at my powers and we're
sitting there and it's someone to come
up and go what goal I was there at the
stadium and then just go
these mates are really horrible
VAR would have ruled out Peter Crouch's
goal versus Trinidad and Tobago in 2006.
three two one
[Laughter]
only to disagree so badly I wanted it
it's a great game but we're doing a
serious show here you can't go pulling
dreadlocks yeah welcome
foreign
newspapers the next day honed in and
your hand was just grabbing
tense I yeah like I'm not proud of it
but I I genuinely had no clue like they
asked me in interviews after do you
think it should be just loud I was like
why yeah they they were saying well
obviously with for the foul and I said I
said I didn't found him yeah I had no
clue like when you're in the moment like
that let's be honest yeah it was a
perfect cross yeah I thought I'm about I
can get above him in I could have seen
him coming outside just I just grabbed
something and just try to like get
leverage you know I had I thought it was
a bit of his shirt and I thought you
know I'd always jump like that you
always try and get you know a little bit
of Leverage but obviously I thought it
was his shirt and I thought no one saw
it but yeah looking back
um it was definitely his hair yeah and
his like neck was back and uh imagine
them in a VAR room oh my God and in the
conversation yep I can see a bit of
shirt and a bit of dreadlock there
he's definitely ruled it out
um but yeah you know Brett so Brett
Sanchez always remember his name right I
met him recently he did obviously the
lad who was defending against me and he
was the minister of sport for Trinidad I
believe it or not right he went on to be
that uh and I was just talking to him
well it was awkward yeah because I got
told by Kevin Jones at Stoke by Dwight
Yorke
um that
to never go to Trinidad
I was like what you know why and they
said obviously you know we were doing
really well against England you know
went to 70 odd minutes
and then obviously that happened and
then yeah I just I'm not well like there
and uh yeah I get it but
um he was obviously he's quite high up
there and stuff and he's invited me to
the Trinidad Carnival yeah so but could
that be a setup
could be yourself not a lovely fella and
he forgave me which is nice because
let's be honest it was a fact yeah it
was a foul svengor and Erickson
underrated as England manager three two
one
foreign
[Laughter]
at the end of the day and we still went
to free he went to three quarterfinals
and we went out in 2002 we went out to
the to the winners hmm 2004 we went out
to the finalists
and in 2006 it was ascending off an
apparently shoot that's a two penalty
shootout
you know
I understand when we get asked the
question all the time I break it down
you know and there was a lot of things
that Sven
Sven
didn't I think with hindsight didn't do
well enough tactically we wasn't
we we could have been a bit more
creative but there's a lot of things at
that era he dealt with a press
incredibly well you remember the you
know he obviously is he's uh let's say
he's um what I try and Joe
you know
you know I think a lot of managers could
have flapped at that there's a lot of
pressure remember the media at the time
I love his reaction to it his reaction
was so smooth he just called a press
conference and basically he said guys
this is my private life
but we're going to do this do this and
then and then you could see him
depressed frothing need we want a story
on a story it's like trying to make it
like a soap drama and I think he calmed
everyone down you know so I think that
that took that took management so that's
why
I think um
I think he was underrated because it was
it was a tough era actually I know we're
great players but it was there were some
things that he'd done well the only
reason I did I'm disagreeing is because
if you say about like dealing with
pressure or being um dealing with the
stick that you got and managing so many
top players of egos yeah then obviously
I'm strongly agree yeah but like
underrated as a manager I don't think he
was under underrated as an England
manager as an England manager no I think
he did well
um he gave me my debut you know I will
have a bad word saying brilliant for me
yeah
um personally yeah but what do I think
he was underrated no I think he got to
the levels that we should have got to
you know and I I agree with you I when
you got locked from getting looked out
by Brazil
um you get knocked out by top sides
maybe that was as good as we were you
know maybe we forget sometimes how good
the other teams are Ronaldo Rivaldo
Ronaldinho that's not bad
you know anyway he only went out to a to
a free fall yeah you know this is our
car I mean we went out the World Cup in
2002 and um I was a Youngster I was like
20 and um
so after the World Cup you cooped up for
four or five weeks doing you know you
don't have a drink whatever and we was
allowed to have a drink in the bar so
some of those were really disappointed
exhausted mentally with her family the
older boys and there was a group of
I was just drinking it got to like
carrying on you know you release all the
attention it's done now we're out the
World Cup and we drew that everyone's
right on holiday ended up at four in the
morning and I ended up with no shirt on
and one of them Jester's hats on you
know the ones that the fans have don't
know how I found it
but I bet go to bed now we're on the
we're on the the plane in three hours so
they'll come down the thing the the uh
I'm on the left and the doors open and
it's Sven and Nancy and I'm thinking
like no light in the moments where
you're like well she got no shirt no
shirt and a Jester's hat on that just be
not that the World Cup I thought I'm
never going to play for England again
this don't look good and I thought I'm
going to commit to it I'm just gonna be
like just just front it I've gone I've
just for something way and they've both
forgotten because both I'm going to live
I went great boss we had a little chat
good night good night bang not mentioned
again now on the other hand a fast order
2010.
I think it just headbutted me
[Laughter]
I think you would have just just gone
Wallop yeah yeah it was chocolate cheese
Fabio Cappello was the strictest manager
I've ever played under three two one
that was sharp that was so easy yeah
like I said Yeah by far like just the
the rules straight away I think there
was you know you go from when you don't
win something with great players like
understand and it was everyone said I
was too relaxed you know players players
were taking control yeah so they just
got the exact opposite yeah they weren't
allowed to do anything anymore this is
the way and that's it yeah the battle
Roy didn't understand the
um you know not being allowed ketchup or
butter or not I'm a huge ketchup but a
man by the way but like why don't take
it away from me not I'm 10 years old and
also I have it in my club you know like
I'm gonna come for three four days on an
England camp and but it's not going to
make a difference it's going to wind me
up yeah you revert back to being a
Schoolboy don't you a little bit so
you're like always trying to get an
angle on something so remember Lads were
like bringing their own ketchup and
everyone's like giggling like oh my God
we've got cookies
come come to room two I'm free we got
some cookies
these Lads have got children
so I remember guys I remember going to
Jermaine jealous right at one point he
was like on the couch giving it the big
enough I've got the um biscuits I love
this gun but listen I've heard that
there's gonna be room chicks
what'd he saying and he's got what
really yeah
apparently that he's human he's heard
the lads of like bringing in bringing in
like contra
so I've just made up this story and I've
reeled him in I've
got him in and I've convinced him right
spot checks I think he said I think he
said and I need to speak to him that he
put the biscuits in the safe
just in case you didn't hit it in the
room
fully grown men all right it's
absolutely ridiculous Peter Crouch's
team of players he played with would
beat Joe Cole's team of players he
played with
three two one
I've played I've played a lot of Clubs
again I reckon five or six of the
players would be the same
yeah yeah yeah if we're talking England
as well yeah the ones we'd have both
Stevie G yeah well let's go for it right
I think you'll keep a beats one I think
I think I think
yeah check yeah
David James yeah Peter checks and
all-time great in Egypt yeah Center Arms
I'll go
JT
and I'm gonna probably mine yeah JT
would go in and I'll probably go in the
interest of I'll probably go I could
have gone cavalio Galas but I'm going to
go Rio above them
too left back Ashley I love Rio as well
yeah and I love
I'd have Ashley but I might yeah okay
I'll go right I was thinking I could
sneak Bale in there as well but what
left back well potentially because I
could sneak him
but no Ashley was a better lift up right
back
I've got you there I reckon
uh
yeah RT mining up Ivanovic the Beast
mate
like cowboy geese
no I don't know you know if I if like
Glenn Jones right and I know
I'm not sure anyone outside who hasn't
played with him would yeah yeah you saw
the best of him I said it's a Portsmouth
he was unbelievable just before he went
to Liverpool different I can see I've
got more defensive yeah okay you know
you've gone like you've gone too
we've just Reign them in too much let's
go and play so free and Mitch will go
free Midfield to the interest of
fairness right I'll go
CVG which we'll both have Steven now and
I'm gonna go Frank
and I'm gonna go Makaveli all right I'll
go Stevie G
I know you're gonna moderate Modric yeah
I don't know whether to go Frank because
that that beats yours didn't it
yeah yeah
um
Modric Frank and Stevie yeah I think I I
would say hold on hold on hold on I've
got a Modric
Stevie Stevie London Alonso yeah I think
you've been here right so we go forwards
right
right this is this is good three up top
three up top Drogba okay drug was my
number nine
just simply because the amount of games
he could he'd win here by himself like
and every Center of I spoke to
give him a nightmare you give a knife so
drug was my number nine what about you
best number nine there's a difficult one
this Torres because I played with him
when he was
destroying teams yes
yeah there's this thing about Torres
because of people remembering the
Chelsea Torres or you know he struggled
a bit later on his career yeah but I
when he turned up and he was destroying
um tops at the halves as well like this
is an age where I think now you know the
center Hearts we had in in our area were
a joke and yeah he was destroying people
yeah so he would be he was the best I've
seen I think I'm gonna go off the left
I'm gonna go Eden
Eden Hazard
played with Leo water plan I I I would
go far to say I think he's the best
player I've played with really yeah
unbelievable and he was a kid I couldn't
believe what I was seeing I couldn't
believe he got left at the team once
because he never trained properly and um
the manager of Rudy Garcia brilliant
manager left him out the team
um and he was the hero there and
he thought he just turned around I'm
going to train properly today and we had
11 aside I think he scored four goals he
scored the best goal I've ever seen on
the football pitch just he got him angry
I've never seen him angry but why why
didn't he train properly though I just
think he just that was him right I just
feel like I remember
he'd just sit there with his like before
again pants on do you know just sitting
there like putting hands just down the
pants like listen to the music like that
and it'll be like a Champions League
game or a big game and it'll be five
minutes to go there'll be other Lads
there with a band's like warming up
doing their mental work stretching
massage and they just get up put his kit
on go out and be the best player like
old school
old school player like in that sense all
right well I've got to play slightly a
different way I'm gonna have Torres oh
hello we'll have I will have two players
Justin behind
wow
yeah because
um Wayne I think
like when he first on the scene right
he's one of the best players I've ever
seen and I think I think we just became
used to his greatness yeah and he could
adapt to any different position he could
play up front on his own remember the
season where he scored 30 goals when he
needed to yeah when someone else took
over that role at Ronaldo or a Tevis you
know you could drop deep into Midfield
yeah Midfield later on in his career
Midfield you know a great passwordable
yeah a great goal scorer yeah and I
think underestimated so I'm gonna put my
on my trump card which I think the match
winner the match winner for me
Arjun Robin coming in after
right on his left Peg I totally agree
with you yeah like so he kind of year
after I was at Chelsea
and you know like the first day training
if someone's planning your position
you're like you want to have a little
look of them see what they've got
because you you know you can pave and I
was like right I was playing on the
right just settled into the team I just
finished you know thinking like I've got
this now then this kid's come over and I
was like oh no for Christ's sake
he was so good there he was quicker than
me he was stronger than me he was like
lovely left foot could do anything and I
was like Wow and like he would have gone
on and played for 10 15 years
for Chelsea and I probably wouldn't have
played I've played nearly 300 games for
Chelsea I probably wouldn't have played
that much
if he would have been fit because he was
so good crowd shooter will you please
see the back of him oh Delight you're
delighted yeah
it's nice and we would love competition
yeah you no not him
[Laughter]
all right could I change mine quickly
I forgot bail dude
yeah well you can change it I mean I'm a
good manager
I'll watch this elevation from like left
back who was struggling for confidence
to then be in a free role yeah and
playing every single game and almost
important player so watching that
um you know the growth of him yeah and
then eventually going to Real Madrid was
yeah was incredible yeah great player I
think it's a very very balanced team
well I think there I think we I mean
it's a good game you'd like to see it
your flare against Marge just like I'll
just I think I'll catch you on a counter
attack to be honest with you will Nick
it
give it to Robin or Hazard and they'll
just go down the wing drop it in Dropbox
imagine Stevie and Modric feeding Torres
and Bale like we could in there hey
there I think we need the next question
Brazil will win the 2022 World Cup three
two one
we're supposed to disagree or what no
no have you seen their lineup well
that's what I I totally agree I think
they've got an incredible score yeah
right the way through nine forward skis
that is like that would have taken sort
of giving it the game away of how
they're going to set up they're going to
bank in try and catch them on the
counter you see when they uh announced
the squad like what yeah
like playing for Brazil's it's a huge
thing yeah the same for everyone but
life in Brazil seems to be like playing
for Brazil is the one like that for me
like you know like you see players you
get 100 caps for certain countries now
but to get a cap for Brazil especially
if you're a forward you you know
straight away you're one of the elite
players in the world like vinicius
Neymar Jesus like the only one that was
a surprise so I'm not surprised because
I love him but Martinelli because he's
just I'll feed that one there they're
bringing him
especially because they've got eight
other forwards I don't think you'll play
much but I think you the next tournament
he could be the star you know think
about the Neymar's getting on a bit of
need so what I plan to bring on though
you know like if you're tired sort of in
extra time yeah bring on Martinelli like
that could be it could be a game changer
do you know what I was thinking as well
like I'm really confident with England
like I've been saying it for months and
months I feel like
I think we're going to do if I'm going
to do it and then just as they were
reeling off the names of the Brazilians
thinking confidence was going down just
losing up like oh how are we going to
stop him oh are we going to stop him I
think we're so like we're so focused on
our country yeah you know that you
forget how strong some of these other
nations are so I don't strongly agree
because I think the France you know
Belgium uh top England have got a chance
you know you've got so many incredible
sides Portugal but um but you you can't
bet against us did I see Danny Alves in
the squad as well he's old did he um
he's like yeah he must be my age
but did you play have you ever play
against it yeah eyes are paid directly
against him unreal like just fit just
and the ladies to say when he's a black
bar so he used to play like you know
like if you're playing the champions
league on a Wednesday night and he'd
have a warm down the next day like your
body was wrecked on it and they said
he'd trained with the lads who didn't
play Train Friday and play again
Saturday
coming into Sunday he's like and he's
still going and he's still in a Brazil
squad unbelievable yeah that is a
version England's World Cup campaign
will be deemed a success three two one
foreign
if this is a success they have to at
least get to a semi-final or final well
I think they will I think and I think
I've watched England every game
since the Euro so no they they come off
it a little bit and there's you know
we're worried about the defense and
everything but
this group they put six the last six
years if you look at their record it's
incredible of the winning games you
think you expect us to get out of the
the group and I think we'll come into
the tournament as the tournament comes
along I just
I just think we need to be brave and I
just think we need to just keep on that
that wave of you know semi-final final
and I'm just going to be optimistic I
strongly agree we're going to do it this
year uh yeah I'm just a little bit I
agree but I'm a little bit more reserved
where do you think the bar is then for
success semi-final yeah I think well the
thing is like we expect now because
we've reached the final of the euros and
then we see the group that we're in you
know we should we should get confidence
out yeah we should score gold
um and I think we will be a success but
like you said before when you look at
the squad stuff other other nations yeah
like I think we've we're really obsessed
with you know just ourselves yeah but I
think we very rarely look outside at
other nations we think yeah look at the
Players we've got and we all we
celebrate our players which is which is
obviously the right thing to do but
until we come home for the tournament
yeah we come over and saw them they went
bad really
um I think that is my only issue
um but we have got we're more than
capable of reached the final
um but I think reaching a semi-final
should still be seen as a success I and
I know that's they're so difficult for
me to say and not what people want to
hear yeah but Gareth Southgate and has
done an amazing job I think there and
you've got some so many incredible
players and players that are comfortable
with you know in possession now it's a
different ball game
um I just think there's some top teams
out there
and I think we need to view a semi-final
potentially as a success I know he's
saying our Grievous framework in this
interview we say about the youngsters so
we're just moving into our new house so
we're gonna have a new we have a new
Telly which my 10 year old son's excited
about just before the World Cup right
and he's he's like Dad that's great we
can watch England in the final on the
Telly I'm like wow that's confident
he just suspects England to get to the
final one
I suppose it's all he's ever known you
know whereas we go hold on a minute mate
you've got a world of pain
let me show you South Africa and Germany
in Japan which I've been an absolute
pleasure mate absolute pleasure I'll see
you at the FIFA World Cup looking
forward to the FIFA World Cup games
strongly agree
brilliant guys we're out there
[Music]
all right
quite funny I remember Emerald heskey
getting there
he was um what did he do again oh yeah
he was on his phone in uh dinner and I
remember you know when you lift off the
trays of the buffet and uh I remember
just throwing the Train the noise that
it made like